heute kochen wir drei köstliche Gerichte
allerdings nicht in normaler Größe
sondern im XXL Format von einer
trüpelpasta über ein Pancake steck bis
hin zu einer 100 Schichten Lasagne viel
Spaß mit diesem Video und jetzt kommen
wir zum Frühstück wir haben nichts
Geringeres vorbereitet als den Inbegriff
eines schönen sonntagsfrühstücks
American Pancakes gigantische Pancakes
wir machen buttermilk Pancakes ich habe
2 ler Buttermilch jede Menge Mehl Zucker
Backpulver Vanillezucker ganz viele Eier
und geschmolzene Butter es ist obwohl
wir so eine Gigant Portion machen echt
gar nicht so schwer deshalb lass uns
direkt anfangen ich gebe mein mehl in
eine große Rührschüssel hab ich auch
knapp über ein Kilogramm Mehl badmilk
Pancakes sind für mich einfach die
besten Pancakes die es gibt besser als
Pfannkuchen besser als kreb das ist
saftig das ist fluffig und das jetzt
hinzubekommen ist unsere Herausforderung
wir wollen natürlich obwohl wir heute
groß Kochen lecker kochen das wird nicht
einfach aber die Gerichte die wir haben
sind wirklich unglaublich ich freue mich
so darauf und das ganze Büro freut sich
schon heute diese Gerichte zu genießen
also Zucker zum Mehl Backpulver rein
zack und Vanillezucker alrght jetzt
schnappen wir uns die Rührmaschine und
los geht's erstmal die trockenen Zutaten
vermengen zack zack zack ganz easy bevor
jetzt die flüssigen dazu kommen boah
junge Alter das ist wirklich schwer das
war kein Schauspiel 2 kg Buttermilch in
so einer Glasschüssel nicht gerade wenig
also Buttermilch drauf ich kann mir gar
nicht vorstellen wie viele Pancakes wir
da rauskriegen wir machen natürlich
trotzd das wird ein crazy Ton ja wir
machen trotzdem große Pancakes breite
Pancakes aber das wird echt viel dann
kommt unsere geschmolzene Butter wie
viel kalorien hat das auch wir müssen
das ja auch gleich noch berechnen ne wir
werden bei jedem Gericht auch die
Kalorien berechnen weil das wird
spannend wie viele Eier ballerst du da
jetzt rein acht Eier acht Eier ja mach
halt nichts ne zum Glück habe ich halt
blockbrett wo ich die Eierschalen direkt
reinwerfen kann aber ist auch bisschen
unfair wenn ich das jetzt sage weil es
ausverkauft aber kommt bald wieder so ab
geht's schnappen wir uns die
Rührmaschine und rühren bin echt froh
dass ich die habe weil sonst hätte ich
safe Muskelkater danach der Trick bei
diesem pancakeeteig egal ob man jetzt
viel oder wenig davon macht ist dass es
relativ grob verbunden ist nur dass man
so ein paar Klumpen noch drin hat weil
dadurch wird der Teig eben dicker und
man hat diese dicken fluffigen Pancakes
das geht aber echt ganz gut von der Hand
habe ich das Gefühl
okay ich gehe jetzt hier gerade noch mit
so einem Teigschaber durch sod dass ich
auch wirklich vom Rand alles abbekomme
und dass das Mehl h noch einzelne Brösel
sich schön in den Teig auflöst langsam
sind wir auch am Ziel angekommen wir
sind h auf einem guten Weg das sieht
wirklich schon sehr sehr sehr gut aus
ich meine damit kannst du wirklich
Pancakes für zwei Familien machen der
Teig ist gerührt wir können anfangen
Pancakes zu backen XXL Pancakes und
dabei hilft mir Eric ein bisschen get
going make Pancakes benutzen nicht eine
Pfanne nicht zwei auch nicht drei vier
pfanneen das wird später unser fertiger
Teller sein wie wie schätzt du wie hoch
werden wir kommen wenn wir den ganzen
dies sehe glaube ich dass wir so ein
Stapel hinkriegen ich find so ein Stapel
wä
wunderschön vielleicht wird noch her
glaube ich ich weiß es nicht so werden
ja die Pancakes sein ungefähr J das wir
crazy wir machen einen Test und zwar
machen wir so gestrichenen Löffel weißt
du D haben wir immer dass wir auch die
Menge haben perfekte Größe schöne Idee
teste mal ob das vielleicht reicht schon
weil es ist echt ein große Kelle so das
läuft ja ein bisschen zu allen Seiten
ich glaube das könnte gut werden oder
vielleicht sogar zu groß der nächster
Versuch bisschen mehr Hitze und schön
mittig rein langsam und langsam mittig
kontrolliert ja der ist schon viel
besser der erste ist fertig wir können
ih wenden und wir können es natürlich
langweilig mit Besteck machen aber s
auch ein bisschen Spannung drin sein oh
der klebt aber gut seid ihr bereit D z
[Applaus]
erster Pancake bisschen zu heiß haben
wir gebacken bisschen trocken ist er
aber wir kriegen das hin lass uns jetzt
einen gigantischen Stapel Pancakes
Backen let go wunderschön sind auf dem
guten Weg Zwischenstand wie sieht
aus ein jiggly Stack auf Pancakes
ungefähr die Hälfte des Teiges ist
vielleicht gerade im Einsatz wird auf
jeden Fall ein ordentlicher steack macht
Spaß die Dinger auszubacken wir haben
eine gute Zeit und mindestens so gut
wird die Zeit wenn wir
gleich
der letzte Pancake wird
geflippt ein F gelandet das hier ist
also unser Stapel einer kommt noch drauf
ich muss sagen es ist wirklich viel ihr
könnt darauf gespannt sein wie viel
Kalorien das sind das ist unglaublich es
ist aber auch nicht so viel wie G das
hätte ich als nächstes gesagt weil ich
finde irgendwie ich hätte mir auch
vorstellen können dass es noch größer
wird das ist aber ich heb das jetzt
einmal hoch oh mein Gott
Alter Alter über 2 Kil safe über 3 Kil
über Kil gagt mit tell das vielleicht 5
kg das pimpen wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen und ich habe noch eine Idee um
euch zu zeigen wie viel das wirklich
[Musik]
ist wir haben ja gerade gesagt es ist
nicht so viel aber es ist wirklich
unglaublich viel wir haben nämlich zum
Vergleich einen normalen Stapel Pancakes
zubereitet und der sieht nebendran so
aus also das ist so was ich an so einem
also klar vielleicht bisschen mehr aber
das ist sowas was ich mir zum Frühstück
machen würde und das hier ist die xx XL
Portion eigentlich wenn man man ehrlich
ist es ist wunderschön es sieht aus wie
direkt aus meinen Träumen und das Essen
wir jetzt es ist Zeit zu
speisen so Mel boah okay komm man
braucht so eine halbe Stunde um durch
den pancakesck
durchzukommen für diejenigen die sich
gefragt haben ich blende es euch jetzt
ein dieser Pancake hat 10 000 Kalorien
dieser pancakeeturm müssen natürlich mal
testen schmeckt das Ding auch Leute
gönnt euch mal ein bisschen was D kann
man auch nicht genug bekommen Arup AR
schmeckt ohne Witz wie der dampft Bro ja
wunderschön also guck mal hier
Buttermilch Pancakes sind für mich die
einzig waren Pancakes die sind fluffig
die sind süß die haben diese Säure von
der Buttermilch es macht einfach Spaß
dreiviertel sind weg wie geht's
euch alle gerade von so oh mein Gott so
am Essen im heutigen Video ernähre ich
mich ja wirklich sehr kalorienreich und
gerade wegen Videos wie diesem ist es
für mich wichtig dass ich im Privatleben
ein bisschen darauf achte was ich so
esse dabei hilft mir yasio sehr denn mit
yaso kann ich meine Kalorien tracken und
bete somit alles im Blick ihr habt ja
gesehen wir haben auch heute bereits
yasio verwendet um genau zu sehen wie
viel Kalorien die Pancakes hat der Salat
den ich hier gerade zubereite hat 500
Kalorien und somit 9500 Kalorien weniger
als die Pancakes heute Morgen und auch
wenn das nicht meine normale
Portionsgröße ist ist es schon gut zu
verstehen was man eigentlich so ist die
Benutzung von yasio ist wirklich
kinderleicht Ihr findet jede Zutat über
die Suche oder könnt sie alternativ
einfach einscannen das Gewicht eingeben
und ihr findet ganz genau heraus wie
viel Kalorien das Gericht mit yasio Pro
was ihr euch mit diesem QRCode oder mit
dem Link in der Beschreibung mit 50%
sichern könnt habt ihr außerdem Zugriff
auf über 2500 Rezepte die euch helfen
eure persönlichen Ziele zu erreichen ihr
könnt außerdem euren Fitness Tracker
verbinden ich habe z.B meine Apple watch
verbunden und kann so perfekt überprüfen
dass ich wenn ich mal ein bisschen mehr
esse ruhig auch ein bisschen mehr essen
kann und wenn ich mich wenig bewege
besser auch ein bisschen weniger esse um
im Defizit zu bleiben gerade für das
neue Jahr checkt yasio aus und sichert
euch yaso pro mit 50% den so kostet
yasio pro nur 2,49 € im Monat ihr findet
über den Link in der Beschreibung
übrigens auch meine Tipps für eure
persönlichen Ziele und weiter geht's mit
unserer 100 Schichten Lasagne ihr habt
gehört was auf dem Plan steht wir
versuchen eine 100 Schichten Lasagne zu
machen also nicht 100 schchichten Nudeln
sondern abwechseln Tomate Nudel
blablabla zwei Töpfe mit Olivenöl Eric
ich darf Dich bitten ein wenig panchetta
auszulassen dann kommt ein wenig
Hackfleisch darauf und wir machen eine
ganz klassische bologaesesoße nur halt
ein bisschen mehr davon als normal und
so macht's doch Spaß so wir holen jetzt
die panchetta raus die ist schön
angebraten schön ausgelassen Küche
raucht stehen unter
Strom zeig euch einmal wie ich das ma
wir formen quasi schon fast so ein
bisschen wie Burger pties so richtige
wie so kleine Teller und jetzt legen wir
das in unseren Topf rein und so kriegt
es halt wunderschöne Röstaromen wichtig
ist dass man wirklich einfach gar keine
Angst vor der Hitze hat ja richtig
Knallgas ich habe in 13 Minuten einen
triseur Termin ich glaub das wird der
Eric übernimmt gleich mal schaut euch
mal an was für eine wunderschöne Farbe
wir hier am Topfboden erzielt haben wir
wenden jetzt unser Hackfleisch wenn wir
es überhaupt sehen können man sieht mich
gar nicht oder also dann holen wir das
Fleisch raus jetzt gerade geht's darum
dass wir diese Röstaromen dran bekommen
und wie es jetzt weitergeht seht ihr bei
Eric guck der Pfannenboden jetzt
Zwiebeln rein Karotten seleri
rein gut durchmischen jetzt Erden wir
noch Knoblauch was wir hier und hier
nämlich noch nicht gemacht haben ist
Tomatenmark hinzufügen und das machen
wir auch noch vorher zack Hälfte der
Tube auf die eine Seite Hälfte der Tube
auf die andere Seite hier ist jetzt auf
jeden Fall wichtig dass wir in dem Topf
noch mal Hitze hinzufügen so wir ballern
jetzt wirklich noch mal richtig hoch mit
der Hitze lassen das einmal kurz stehen
und dann löschen wir mit Rotwein ab
ruhig mit einem ordentlichen Schluck und
spätestens jetzt sollte alles vom
Pfannenboden verschwunden sein
wunderschön zu dem Rotwein kippen wir an
jedem Topf auch noch ein Glas Brühe und
wenn du das richtig gemacht hast dann
kannst du eigentlich kaum noch was
falsch machen jetzt hast du Geschmack
hoch 1000 in den Topf drin so wir fügen
einmal das Fleisch wieder zurück können
jetzt beide Töpfe auch schon mal ein
bisschen runter tun auf mittlere Hitze
und ganz wichtig auch den Fleischsaft
und ihr merkt überhaupt nicht schlimm
dass das Fleisch noch nicht ganz durch
ist das köchelt jetzt eh noch mindestens
eine dreiviertel Stunde hier das gleiche
auch auf der anderen Seite und auch den
panchetter boah der ist richtig knusprig
bisschen da das ist so eine Schweinerei
Alter schön unterrühren boah das sieht
einfach nur traumhaft aus ich tu ein
bisschen Fleisch noch hier rüber weil
der Topf ist bisschen größer und jetzt
würde ich sagen passierte Tomate ein und
zwei gut umrühren jetzt wir haben zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt bewusst noch gar kein
Salz und Pfeffer hinzugefügt weil das
machen wir am Ende genau so lassen wir
das jetzt mindestens eine halbe Stunde
köcheln dass es einfach noch mal ein
bisschen einzieht dass das Fleisch gar
wird dass das Gemüse auch ein bisschen
köcheln kann und in der Zwischenzeit
kümmern wir uns um die rikotta und die
beschamel und nicht irgendwie sondern
mit einem ganzen Block Butter und das
habe ich noch nie gemacht aber ich werde
es jetzt zum ersten Mal machen wir
nehmen uns ein Gefäß was dem gerecht
wird und lassen als allererstes die
Butter schmelzen die Butter ist
geschmolzen wie ihr seht und jetzt
müssen wir bchamel machen das wird
wirklich spannend so alleine eine kleine
wischermehl machen ist immer schon so
eine kleine tricky Aufgabe und jetzt
werde ich ganz vorsichtig das Mehl
addden nach und nach und dabei
ordentlich rühren das Ziel ist dass wir
am Ende so eine so eine Masse
hinbekommen eine helle Masse aus Mehl
und Butter und hier geht's wirklich
einfach nur um Konsistenz wie ihr seht
ist Butter und Mehl jetzt mittlerweile
zu so einer klebrigen Masse geworden und
das ist der Zeitpunkt wo wir die Milch
hinzufügen immer auf Konsistenz achten
und dabei rühren nicht zu heiß werden
lassen und das ist gar nicht so leicht
bei so viel Menge wer kommt denn da hör
mal du machst das ja ein a ich versuch's
frisch vom Friseur Max was sagst du
wunderschön tolle Bechamel hier muss man
einfach jetzt Stück für Stück sich
rantasten nicht alles Milch reinkippen
und dann rühren sondern immer ein
bisschen und dann gucken wie die
Konsistenz ist H so Freunde wir sind
jetzt zurück wir haben eine bologese
gekocht und eine beschamelsoße mit wir
meine ich in diesem Fall Eric der mich
vertreten hat in der Zwischenzeit noch
mal von vorne er hat mich bestmöglich
vertreten wir haben hier eine
wunderschöne bechamellsoße die wirklich
ein Traum geworden ist man könnte meinen
der Junge hat das schon mal gemacht
unglaublich die müssen wir noch mal
abschmecken dafür habe ich ein wenig
Muskatnuss die fügen wir hinzu so wie
Salz die bolonese kocht ist noch relativ
flüssig aber da wir mit Lasagneplatten
arbeiten die noch nicht vorgekocht sind
sollte das kein Problem sein dann haben
wir auch schon drei unserer Schichten
fertig wir machen fünf Schichten sogar
Bolognese Nudeln Ricotta Bechamel und
Käse Decker das heißt für 100 layers
brauchen wir 20 Schichten und einrühren
bevor wir unsere Fleischsoße einsetzen
gehe ich noch mal mit so einem
Kartoffelstampfer rein dass die Brocken
die wir quasi beim Anbraten hatten sich
auflösen und das alles ein gleichmäßigen
Biss bekommen jetzt wird's noch mal
richtig spannend für unsere Kleidung
denn jetzt schütten wir die Bolognese in
diese große Schüssel dass wir aus einer
Schüssel arbeiten können alter Schwede
jetzt Schichten wir die Lasagne in
diesem Gigant von einem Behälter es ist
soweit wir können beginnen zu schichten
und wir Schichten mit Lasagneplatten
Tomatensoße Ricotta geriebenem Käse und
bechamellsoße es ist wirklich ein
absolutes Massaker also zunächst starten
wir mit ein wenig Soße das ist einfach
wirklich so ein Tropfen auf einem heißen
Stein ne also unglaublich das Gefäß ist
auch so tief dass ich da so kaum
reinfüen kann wirklich crazy okay das
sieht auch schon mal gut aus dann als
nächstes nehmen wir immer 1 Z D Platten
von unserer Lasagne Nummer ein Nummer Z
und Nummer dre so weiter geht's mit
unserem ricotter davon ma ich einfach so
kleine klexse in unsere Form ihr merkt
schon das dauert ewig wenn ich das so
mache deshalb helfen wir die Jungs
gleich aber wir haben noch einen Trick
in petto und zwar werden wir diese Form
wenn sie einmal komplett gesetzt Pressen
mit der anderen Form s dass Sie kompakt
ist alles verteilt ist und wir uns jetzt
ein bisschen unsaubere Arbeit leisten
können ALR weiter geht's mit Bechamel
also bechamellsoße einfach Tropfen wir
können auch keine großen großen layers
überhaupt machen weil wir auch einfach
100 haben wollen und zum Abschluss was
parmesaräse sowie etwas Mozzarella
fertig ist die erste Lage die erste Lage
aber eigentlich sind ja jetzt schon fünf
lagenau fertig sind die ersten Lagen von
unserer 100 lagen Lasagne mama mia leute
das ist wirklich Arbeit also wenn
Restaurant 100 Schichten Lasagne auf der
Karte hat dann wisst ihr die geben sich
Mühe und wir gucken jetzt mal wie viel
Platz wir kriegen wenn wir das Ganze
einmal stopfen leg ein bisschen
Backpapier oben drauf wir sind schon bis
zum Rand voll und Bo so viel passiert
gar nicht nee n also aber mach mal
wirklich mit mit deinem gesamten Gewicht
guck mal dann kommt an der Seite die
Soße raus ja
geil okay komm das passt und ein
bisschen Platz haben wir dadurch mehr
bekommen aber nicht so viel wie
ursprünglich gedacht das heißt wir
machen noch zwei drei Schichten drauf
und dann sind wir fertig Leute ich hätte
nicht gedacht wie viel am Ende des Tages
in diesen Behälter hier reinpasst ich
meine wir haben die gesamte
Bolognesesoße fast aufgebraucht das ist
vielleicht noch für eine Portion Nudeln
kann man sich perfekt die nächsten Tage
noch gönnen das wiegt bestimmt 7 kg Kil
ja hätte ich auch gesagt jetzt ma ich
den Rücken so kaputt nur aus
Schulter alter Schwede das ist wirklich
das ist wirklich krank ich habe Angst
dass der Ofen das nicht tragen kann 185°
Umluft und rein da das biegt sich
wirklich und ich schätze das dauert
jetzt bestimmt anderthalb Stunden und
dann sehen wir das hier hinten wieder
während wir auf die Lasagne warten
machen wir eine schnelle trüffelpasta
ihr wisst natürlich dass es keine
normale Portion ist sondern eine XXL
Portion im käseleib das wollte ich schon
immer mal machen in einem echten
Parmesankäse eine trüffelpasta
zuzubereiten und es war wirklich nicht
leicht daranzukommen Leute ich sag's
euch wir haben man kann die Dinger
natürlich kaufen ne aber all das was
hier fehlt hätten wir rauskratzen müssen
und was weiß ich was damit machen müssen
deshalb haben wir bei einem Restaurant
angerufen und haben gefragt können wir
euch einen benutzten käseleib abkaufen
hier ist das Ding 160 € hat das gekostet
das gute Stück hier der Ablauf ist
denkbar einfach also wir haben einen
riesigen parmesanleib den wir komplett
füllen wollen mit Pasta dafür nutzen wir
zweinhalb Kilo Spaghetti und wir machen
eine kleine Sahnesoße die ich hier in
dieser Pfanne beginne deshalb mache ich
sie heiß geb ein bisschen Butter
hinein das war gerade voll der Glitch da
drüben habe ich zwei Trüffel Produkte
mit denen ich arbeiten werde einmal ein
P Tee Trüffel Aroma und eine Trüffel
bututter die einfach ein brutalen
Trüffelgeschmack hat Zwiebel geschnitten
die glasieren wir einfach in der
Zwischenzeit schneide ich den Knoblauch
und dann geben wir den auch dazu zwiebel
und Knoblauch sind glasig das heißt für
mich ist die Zeit gekommen ein wenig
Sahne darüber zu geben und mit ein wenig
meine ich knapp 500 ml wir wollen
wirklich aber verhältnismäßig zu den
Nudeln nicht so viel Sahne sondern mehr
auch Cremigkeit durch den Parmesan
bekommen sonst hätten wir in ja gar
nicht kaufen müssen also die Sahne
schmilzt blubbert jetzt ein bisschen vor
sich hin und in der Zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal anfangen Parmesan zu
kratzen weil mit diesem Löffel hier
werde ich jetzt so kleine
parmesanflocken lösen so wie es im
Restaurant gemacht wird sodass die
später durch Nudelwasser durch unsere
Sahnecreme geschmolzen werden und wir
hier drin einen absoluten Traum einer
trüffelpasta anrichten können wir kochen
ein paar Nudeln unsere Sahnesoße ist
fertig und die schmecken wir jetzt
einmal ab wir geben ordentlich Tat Vater
dazu ein trüffelp und dann der heilige
trüffelgi Butter vom weißen Trüffel und
geben Sie einfach hinzu sieht wenig aus
aber das Zeug ist brutal jetzt rühren
wir das ganze ein und ich glaube dann
entsteht auch direkt schon die Optik die
wir wollten nämlich diese cremige
trüffeloptik wir geben dazu noch Pfeffer
und eine Prise Salz denn der ganze
Parmesan hat ja auch jede Menge Salz
damit sollten wir fein sein alles ist
aufgelöst wir geben jetzt die Soße in
unseren parmesanle ich bin wirklich
gespannt denn wenn alles gut läuft
verbinden Sie sich jetzt schon sonst
setze ich darauf dass es gleich passiert
wenn wir die heißen Nudeln drauf geben
also ab in den parmesanleib
Ali alter Schwede drehen drehen drehen
rühren rühren rühren natürlich kann man
danach den parmesanleib noch weiter
verwenden indem man den einmal sauber
abkratzt schöpfen uns auf jeden Fall
auch gut Nudelwasser ab dass wir gleich
einfach sehr sehr flexibel sind mit dem
nachjustieren Zeit die Nudeln
abzugießen h comes the pasta los geht's
rein in den
käseleit los geht's betet für mich dass
es cremig wird Alter schwe hörst du das
ja ich hö das können uns übrigens auch
für Hochzeiten buchen Großveranstaltung
jeder Art ich würde sagen Zeit zum Essen
oder ich glaube auch glaub da können
sich jetzt ein paar Leute sehr drüber
freuen alter
Schwede ja das ist einfach Traum und wie
immer leute seht ihr jetzt gerade
eingeblendet wie viel Kalorien diese
käsepasta hat ich glaube ein paar
Cremigkeit ist wirklich on point ne
häufig kriegst du die im Restaurant
nicht so cremig probieren wir die
trüpelpasta ich B wirklich kaum gar
nicht aus dem Schwitzen raus aber es hat
wirklich Spaß gemacht die zuzubereiten
und mit so ein Parmesan reit das ist
einfach
unglaublich und jetzt hat auch richtig
schön viel leckeren Trüffelgeschmack
Trüffelgeschmack du hast Knoblauch du
hast Herz ohne Witz für eine
Familienfeier lohnt sich so ein
parmesanrad ja übelst geil wir genießen
jetzt alle unseren Teller Pasta und dann
sollte auch irgendwann schon die Lasagne
fertig sein aber ich GL wir brauchen ein
kleines Päuschen bis wir uns die heute
Abend können schauen wir uns jetzt
einmal unsere Lasagne an also das habe
ich noch nie gesehen das ist wirklich
unglaublich also nicht mehr und nicht
weniger und es gibt ein Problem wenn wir
die Lasagne jetzt umdrehen aufschneiden
dann hat sie noch nicht die Festigkeit
die es braucht weil sie halt noch weich
ist quasi noch kocht innen drin wir
müssen sie jetzt abkühlen lassen und wir
müssen uns jetzt auch extrem betrinken
bei unserer Weihnachtsfeier das habe ich
getan deshalb seht ihr mich jetzt einen
Tag später ein bisschen angeschlagen
hier in der Küche aber umso mehr freue
ich mich über unsere Lasagne die jetzt
die ganze Nacht draußen geruht hat 100
Schichten soll sie haben um ehrlich zu
sein ich habe gestern nicht mitgezählt
ich bin gespannt wenn wir sie gleich
aufschneiden wie viel es wirklich
geworden sind aber ich denke auch dass
das Ruden wirklich wichtig war hätten
wir die gestern aufgeschnitten das wäre
nichts geworden also wie machen wir das
jetzt am besten das Ding ist wirklich
super schwer ich habe mir gedacht ich
nehme vielleicht das Brett hier boah
junge Alter ich die ist gerade wirklich
einfach runter im Keller gefallen mit
dieser Lasagne und jetzt ist die Frage
wie kriegen wir sie raus einfach mal ein
bisschen sie löst sich sie löst sich
vorsichtig seid ihr bereit 100 Schichten
Lasagne 3 2
[Musik]
1 alter Schwede ich brauch das so
dringend gerade das war die beste
Entscheidung das heute zu
machen was ist das für ein Monster sieht
wirklich aus wie ein Monster so ein
bisskan Bro und wir schneiden die
Lasagne
[Musik]
an 100 Schichten
Lasagne 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 18 19 20 über 20
und wir haben ja gemacht ein Schicht
Nudeln einicht dies einicht das also 100
Schichten erfolgreich erreicht sehr gut
jetzt müssen wir nur noch testen ob das
ganze auch schmeckt also machen wir uns
einen schönen Teller fertig und genießen
die ganz in
[Musik]
Ruhe
hast du einen neuen Freund gefunden nen
ih
bollomann das sieht wirklich sehr sehr
besonders aus also es hat auch so viel
Spaß gemacht das zu stapeln und so ich
war richtig wie meinem Film ich habe
mich Gefühl das würde ich LEGO bauen
oder so so haben wir das ganze jetzt
angerichtet noch ein bisschen Bolognese
unten von allen Seiten so eine Scheibe
angebraten und ich sage euch ganz
ehrlich das ist alleine schon eine
Doppel Portion im Restaurant würdest du
die Hälfte davon bekommen ich freue mich
so sehr darauf das zu essen ich glaub
das wird mich auch gut nach vorne
bringen dann probieren wir mal die 100
Schichten Lasagne es war jetzt gerade
beim Schneiden schon merklich knusprig
also mal rein in die Soße und ganz
ehrlich wir können schon bisschen stolz
auf uns sein weil alles was wir heute
gegessen haben war nicht nur groß
sondern auch wirklich lecker wenn diese
Lasagne es auch
ist es ist wirklich krass alle
Nudelplatten sind perfekt weich haben
trotzdem noch ein leichten Biss diese
Bolognese herzhaft es ist saftig es
macht einfach Spaß zu essen und
irgendwie dch dass man weiß dass das aus
diesem dicken Oschi kommt ist es noch
viel geiler und ihr seht jetzt schon wie
viel davon weg ist ne ich habe all ein
bisschen was vorbeigebracht an
Arbeitsplatz alle bestens versorgt aber
die Hälfte davon nehme ich nach Hause
mit die andere Hälfte nimmt Eric dann
haben wir auch die Bolognese besiegt ihr
seht wie immer den Kalorienwert
eingeblendet den dieses Monster
ursprünglich hatte bevor wir angefangen
haben es aufzuessen
29000 Kilokalorien 29000 Kalorien ein
Tag XXL Kochen hat richtig Spaß gemacht
schreibt in die Kommentare wenn ihr das
ganze noch mal sehen wollt weil es gibt
mit Sicherheit noch viele Gerichte mit
denen wir das machen können falls ja
freue ich mich wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dahin ciao
ciao m